I've always been a writer I've always
known I could write a book the fact that
I wrote a book without any help without
any collaborator without any Ghost
Writer was your publisher shocked that
you were able to write the book on your
own which is such a massive oh this was
a massive battle this was a matter of my
book agent that I was introduced to he
sat down with me at the Beverly Hills
Hotel and he goes now you're gonna write
a book you're gonna need some help let's
put a little proposal together and you
know we'll help you all along the way
and then by you know fires shooting out
of my ears I'm like yes okay let me just
give it a shot and then I just started
writing my first memory to my last and
it became this kind of 60 page poem and
I showed it to him and he goes okay well
we'll work on this and we'll maybe show
it and he goes he called me back and he
said I've showed this to other people
and I think we might actually use this
proposal to show Publishers and I said
okay then I met Publishers and they said
okay well we're going to think about a
ghost writer and a collaborator and but
and then one lady was like I really like
your writing style and I said I'm only
doing this if I can write it myself and
she went okay let's give it a shot but
if you don't if you can't come through
we'll bring somebody in or we had a deal
that I could walk away and they could
walk away
so I worked on it and it became so close
and I just needed some help shaping it
and they said all we need is an editor
and so she edited it with me and I
learned how to edit myself I even had
the page on the screen so I can make the
track changes myself I won't even let
them do it but they helped me with the
editing so it was my book in the
documentary your mom says to you why
don't you put on some nice dresses or
something like that she's I don't
remember it exactly but you say to her
nobody wants to see my body anymore do
you really feel that way is that I you
know I went through kind of a crazy time
writing the book I mean I started
writing my book and I put on like 25
pounds crazy really I did you I did and
I look back at it and I see how it was
the book process because as I wrote my
book I didn't change too much I mean I
was drinking earlier with the husband
and stuff but I um lost it all at the
end of my book it was crazy it was crazy
but I had a physical reaction to telling
my story it was almost like I was
hanging on to something I couldn't you
know it was a protective my puffy suit
of armor I don't know what it was it was
so much it was like thinking about some
kind of protection I don't know what it
was because my body was just reacting it
wasn't like I was eating any different
I'm vegan I eat nuts and berries you
know I don't eat them a lot but I was my
body was changing and I thought well
maybe I'm just getting old and this is
it and I was walking around in caftans I
mean I looked ridiculous and my mama
said you never want to show your figure
anymore and I just felt like butt finger
and I said you know I just was kind of
joking but I look at that and I think I
was a mess at that time so I kind of
like that I peeled back everything no
makeup nothing like that and I thought
you know what if you like me like this
if you like me at my worst
maybe you like me